bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono affari j
oggi andiamo avanti con scribblenauts
unlimited avevamo di passi che diventerà
ministro posto isola puntino perfetto mi
ricordavo più il nome veramente fantacci
finora penso sia uno dei posti più belli
che abbia mai visitato in sfide mouse e
c'è chi cazzo è questo voglio immergermi
ma non all equipaggiamento appropriato
bastano le pinne spero perché altro non
mi viene in mente tieni
sì però devi ok perfetto ma fai fatto
tutto tuo
va bene posso venire ranocchia buon dio
che cazzo è stato dio è una petroliera
cosa dovrei farci arrampicati possa
arrampicarmi sulla petroliera è ok
che cosa strana poco strana vabbè
comunque e fiammante quindi direi il
diluvio andiamo a togliere il fuoco
perché non va bene
se sei ok per te emergenza petrolifera
ce l'abbiamo fatta
cazzo come non detto e andato tutto a
[ __ ] di nuovo perfetto
e che cazzo non ho fatto in tempo ad
aggiustarle andata più a [ __ ] di
prima ma non importa andiamo avanti c'è
perché c'è uno scienziato sul tetto
devo hai bisogno di qualcosa no perché
perfetto saranno non rompo le palle fai
quello che vuoi probabilmente si sta
pranzando e devo andare avanti chi è
questo la sua bellissima voce mister
notiziando ok allora dobbiamo fare devo
aiutarti faceva sordo sordo cosa
marinaio ammaliato io più che altro
adesso direi ammalato ma non importa
mi dispiace lo sono così solo aiutami a
migliorare la voce per trovare un amico
intonata perfetto c6 c7
direi che direi che un fit con pitbull
lo puoi anche fare quindi va bene che
cazzo è quella roba
ok c'era il kraken c'era il kraken non
ho fatto in tempo a vederlo maledizione
volevo vederlo perché vabbè pazienza c'è
anche c'è anche la perla nera cioè tutto
cos'è questo un teschio
vabbè c'è un tipo che fa le flessioni
non so per massimi da pirate sono il
capitano di quella nave uncino michael
uccido strumento sia uguale vai sei un
pirata a tutti gli effetti non ha
veramente forse era era l'altro uncino
arma questo qui mi sa che era questi
sono cazzo sono qua a quello andava bene
questo va bene l'altro nova best erano
identici ma non fa niente
cosa vuoi tu avessi mila vichinghe sono
il capitano di quella nave el moda di
vichingo perfetto vai cos'è è diventato
un maschio sei un pirla è ma sono tutti
i capitani qui manca quello manca il
vero capitano qui ragazze non va bene
jack sparso è lui è lui il vero capitano
perché è sì lo so che ti serve una
moglie jack e sei un vichingo sì jack è
un vichingo come si deve però deve
andare 18 cosa cazzo mi significa tutto
questo
direi di andare avanti c'è una destra o
c'è un altro scienziato marinaio sordo e
lui ho fatto un'altra joe d'amico cosa
per chiamare i soccorsi
mega megafono megafono by ci sei
perfetta adesso chiamati cazzo vuoi
oddio sono arrivati veramente cioè
elicottero
volevo no volevo salire anch'io
maledizione vabbè non fa niente c'è un
capitano perfetto
questo è uno strano quello del tonno
aiuti al guardiano aspettare un attimo
che prima c'è questo qui che non ho
capito che cazzo vuole se qualcuno cambi
essere condizioni meteo potrai trovare
il castello galleggiante il castello
galleggiante inteni la piattaforma di
prima è andato a [ __ ] comunque va beh
non ti serve la pioggia penso si no
veramente dovrei togliere la pioggia no
va bene tu con la pioggia ci vai senza
pioggia no vabbè sono tattiche tu hai
queste va bene così buona fortuna per il
castello galleggiante è cazzo c'era
davvero ci possa andare anch'io è
fantastico
stai attento non la terra lontana voglio
andarci anche io veramente si può fare
nel caso faccio
maicon si può volante veloce cazzo
faccio ad andare laggiù voglio andarci
che figo
ma veramente un cast cerci posso proprio
andare una zona ma quale ha e questo non
lo sa torre favola perfetto ora
andiamoci dopo che prendo la st wright è
tra l'altro notate che effetti di
allontanamento epici comunque vabbè
andiamo sul marinaio qui smettila di
piovere qualche a [ __ ] aiuto a guardare
le fare a proteggere fare la tempesta
mai cos'è una notte buia e tempestosa
fantastico direi di iniziare
sono prontissimo c'è anche la buongiorno
signora è in arrivo una tempesta
perfetto come se non bastasse click che
inonderà l'isola la maglia del guardian
e le farà bisogno di qualcosa dove
mettere i gioielli scrigno effetto
screen mai così ci siamo
bene la prima è andata cosa volete dopo
che le dico oddio lo pilota la vecchia e
one non c'è la parte dietro l'elicottero
ma che cazzo che che elicottero era
quello e vabbè c'è che cosa vuole quella
cioè non possiamo trasmettere con questa
tempesta che ha qualcosa di lungo e
sottile per potenziare il segnale
antenna con l'unica cosa cazzo
l'unica è sottile l'unica cosa parte
anatomica dispositivo vai col
dispositivo non è proprio sottile ma va
bene è una tenda volante
va bene così e abbastanza sì che cazzo
stai facendo oddio oddio santissimo ma è
un tetto resistente quello ovvio che
cazzo stai facendo una radio madonna
neanche le centrali radio hanno una roba
così sta veramente piove parecchio c'è
l'isola sta per essere sommersa e
atlantide
mantieni la la lanterne del faro sopra
l'acqua fino a quando non retrocederà
altrimenti la nave in arrivo una fra
ghera ok ragazzi sono ok se no ho
distrutto l'antenna merda
vabbè pazienza non fa niente mai
mandiamo cos'è perfetto sta distruggendo
le nuvole col bazooka senza motivo ma va
bene ci sono
ok vabbè ho vinto ce l'ho fatta dopo un
secolo ce l'ho fatta
effetto ragazzi sono allora abbiamo
preso la 42
42 42 esima sarai se ne rimangono tipo 8
per arrivare all'ultima zona perfetto
allora devo riuscire ad arrivare almeno
a 45
e questo in questa puntata di scrivere
non tanto andiamo avanti c'era il
castello fanta la torre favola perfetto
entriamo ho paura di ritrovarci non so
che coop perfetto che cazzo è suo zio
cosa cos'è cos'è
oddio cosa ma perché ho il mio dio santi
cos'è hansel e gretel a spasso aiuta
hansel e gretel a sopravvivere a questo
racconto straziante vai è una cosa senza
senso ma va bene hansel e gretel a
spasso inizia ok perfetto c'è anche
mammolo hansel e gretel sono in
esplorazione da di qualcosa per lasciare
una traccia mangime non te l'ho già dato
prima vanno una funzione le noccioline
todato non va bene
beh no attento cazzo non sto a far
mangiare balletto uccello del calcio ma
ti prendo brutto stronzo di merda vai a
farti cazzi tuoi cazzo ne so che si
mangia tutto che risate i sassolini
mangiati mangiati questi brutto stronzo
quel sassolino solo va bene da questo è
un sassolone questo non è piccolo il
sasso ma quanti cazzo ce ne sono
aiuta l'anziano a tagliare la legna a
tagliare della legna portava nella stufa
ok ma è normale che tutto assi e
ovviamente la casale gigante non ha
avuto un'infanzia ma va beh non me lo
ricordavo e basta poi potresti tagliare
della legna per il fuoco mente alla
nella stufa te ne sarò per sempre grato
va bene della legna
e accetta ok lascia faccia facciamo un
ascia ok ci dovremmo essere però è un po
è più grossa di melassa
ma non importa ma che cos'è tagliamola
lei è perfetto ci siamo io lascia me la
tengo non si sa mai
bene stanno facendo tutto loro va bene
così
la vecchia c'è uno stile che veramente
fantastico siete caduti in trappola rete
sarà la mia schiava e hansen sarà la mia
cena
addio o che cazzo è una vecchia zombie
ecco lo sapevo che gli occhiali
servivano a coprire gli occhi dai
qualcosa aster per trarre in inganno la
strega non farsi mangiare fabbrichiamo
fa vijay dargli da mangiare lui perfetto
ok cosa cazzo sta facendo mista
stuprando no non è esattamente quello
che avevo in mente però va bene elimina
fa vj
si fa vi lo so che sei spaventato sono
spaventato anch'io devi devi no ti sta
mangiando anche la vecchia lievito
strazio facciamo prima cosa devo fare
per far distrarre ansa che cazzo ne so
aggiunge aggettivo facciamo che ne so
scaduto si scatenò scaduto non va bene
allora ammuffito perfetto lo break che
cazzo dovrebbe farci guadagnare un po di
tempo a dire la strega verso il porno e
bambino fabbrichiamo un bambino verso
forno anche se è un po strano come cazzo
che sta succedendo è un'orgia sbrigati
gretel tocca a te o che cosa però ok sta
portando la vecchia perfetto il bambino
a fuoco attenzioni di ha già succedendo
di tutto da leggere morte del momento di
liberare hansel e andarsene
ansell in gara sarebbe svezia di
bruciare è la chiave calda va bene ogni
portate voi libera a questo sarebbe
garage vai se la megera è morta il
momento di liberare la stella andarsene
perfetto ce l'abbiamo fatta
si sia per ok perfetto ci siamo
addio e gex falso e lui si è fatto
crescere la barba è diventato un
naufrago ed è tornato dall'isola con la
barba oddio corrente a casa bambini
grazie mille per averli protetti prendi
questo
e last rites prefetto si è però io sono
diventato uno gnomo devo tornare normale
maledizione
vabbè c'è la sorella che più grossa di
me ma va bene lo stesso hansel e gretel
a spasso completato 43 st wright sono
contentissimo
devo devo andare a trovare gigante prima
per chi è questo e pinocchio e pinocchio
con un naso un po strano
il mio naso si allunga se è bugiardo io
resto puoi prenderlo normale se prometto
ad essere onesto guarda che tu dica la
verità almeno mi interessa ma già mai
rotto il cazzo quindi quel naso ti resta
ma che cazzo di richieste sono ma
mettiamo negli a sto punto metterei
negli aggettivi sincero ok ok perfetto
il naso a naso era una battuta perché
non faceva ridere ma non importa è
diventato justin bieber
ok
vabbè va bene anche sparita oddio cioè
del fumo aiuto a chi cazzo è questo
oddio pastore femminile ha prima volta
aveva un agnellino che avrei voluto
cucinare
aiutami ritrovarlo perché non so dove
cercare ma che cazzo ma quanto e
gentilezza tu dimostri ma perché per una
volta non vi fate il cassino c'è che
cazzo c'è poi marley che dorme
aiutami a trovare mio amore reale così
lei si rivelerà a quello non è bob
marley e la principessa sul pisello
vabbè del cibo minuscolo sotto il
materasso sentirà
ok devo scriverlo proprio io direi
pisello a sto punto anche se ok meno
male che mi ha fabbricato quello giusto
oh cazzo sposa ideale fantastico
ora poi quello è un fratello di maxwell
ok perfetto e mi sembrava bob marley
quella lì con gli occhiali va bene è un
file assurdo ma non importa ok basta che
siete con te che cazzo cieli sopra ci
sono dei addio
cos'è chi è questa no pil dallo specchio
dice che non sono bella ma fa tanto male
questa novella ma avete rotto il cazzo
questa filastrocca al prossimo un calcio
in culo li tocca
vabbè facciamo aggiunge aggettivo
mettiamo bella lei a sto punto c no
veramente questo ok c'è un anonymous
nello specchio come cazzo ci arrivo di
sopra
devo devo uscire da qualche parte in
qualche modo perfetto cioè ci siano c'è
la finestra o chi cazzo è quella
buongiorno il nostro amore non mi fa
vivere se solo avessimo altro da
condividere c'è ma col topo con la tipa
dietro non ho capito a voi magari devo
farla gigante anche a lei
il nostro ok perfetto da giganti gigante
bene ok chi siamo
oh cazzo è diventata si è sempre
abbastanza bassa con questi topi la
situazione infernale ci vuole qualcosa
di musical e vai col piffero
ok in questa sta puntanto e piena di
doppi sensi raga ma non importa
pifferaio nel pane era veramente un
pifferaio io ho tirato fuori il primo
strumento musicale mi è venuto in mente
si stanno suicidando
ok
e va bene devo andare devo trovare un
passaggio per entrare di sopra
maledizione cieco odio c'è un gatto il
gesto con gli stivali aiutami amico mia
o mia o ci voleva non te ne andare con
gli stivali aiutami a levare o tanto
soffiato in un occhio energia la casa di
questo con cellino aiutami a far volar
via devono farsi soffiare io guarda un
fusto l'udace lo metterei che la metà
basta che cazzo vuoi che ne so io
ventilatore michael aria o mio dio che
cazzo un porcelli è bastato il
ventilatore cioè non ho capito
al contrario tra l'altro va bene un
importo perché se bevi maxwell per
favore fammi scendere prima che cade mi
metto a piangere quindi omette nerissimo
mio zio che lasciamo perdere
come ci sei finito lì sopra sono anche
grande però mi sta ancora cito ancora
nella culla ma va bene prendiamo una che
restò wine shuttle uno shock tolse 66
pilotarlo uno shuttle vai giù o cazzo
mai lasciare i drogati né gli shuttle ok
sta accadendo
no kat si è fatto male è tutto a posto
non è neanche pianto bene ma mi sento
veramente sei già giu comunque la pesca
la guaina una scala strumento te lo
ammetto anche se si è acceso adesso stai
salendo c'è ma cazzo vuoi scendere o
salire non ho capito
lasciate un secondo però che c'è ancora
su questa qua che non ho visto io
soltanto d'armi in anteprima del
prossimo episodio anche se non so o mio
dio
benvenuto l'abisso all'iterazione ceo
dio che casino
c'è un suo zio che figo la sfida del
sottomarino la vogliono formare hungry
shark è l'applicazione che ciò per
l'android sì ho mal di denti dami
qualcosa per curarti sì lo farò la
prossima volta si perfetto e direi di
chiudere qui l'episodio ragazze video è
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovate nella descrizione se
non siete ancora i siti iscrivetevi noi
ci vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi